Nó này mùa tháng 1 năm 2018, tổng thống Mỹ đường nàn Xam Tinh mũ, nước này đã tế thành một cuộc tấn công
huy mô lớn nhằm vào vên niềm duy ra và bác sữ tổng thống Nicolas Maduro, đồng thời đưa ông Xà Hỏi
lãnh Thủ Vên niềm duy ra. Ông Xam Tinh biết, Chil Zik được thực hiện với hội với các cơ quan thực tý pháp lột Mỹ và mua tả đây là một Chil Zik Tinh
Ông Xam Khong Bồ Chítết về địa điểm xam sữ hay tình chẳng hiện tại của ông Maduro, sau trở biến sẽ cố cấp thiền thông tin trong thế giới.
Bây giờ phía phía phía niềm duy ra, phó tổng thống Điao C, Rồi Gay, sức hiện trên trên đình nhé nước cho biết, chính quyền nước này không só tụi tụi của tổng thống Maduro và Phu Nen Silia Ferres,
đồng thời yêu cầu phía Mỹ của các bằng chữ cho thấy hai người có sống. Nhà chức chất phía niềm duy ra đã bán bố tình chạm mất ủng vinh hoai, cho phép mở giống và chọn của lực lượng vú trang.
Theo hảo tin, các vụ nổ đã được ghi nhận tại thủ đô Kỳ Cà Cá s, của ngày. Chí phủ vinh niềm la các bột Mỹ tình công các bột tiêu xử và quân sự,
hóa đoa là hình đậm xâm được và kêu vọng nghe dân số đường phà đối.
Theo Roto, đoa tuyên bố càng tiếp chức khi em hoa của Mỹ vào vinh niềm duy ra và lần đầu tiên,
hoa sình tượng thực hiện hình đậm con sự khi mô lớn tại phục Mỹ là tình. Kể tương nămu nhìn chính xam cám em chiến.
Hãy video về phép vinh này dù em la hệ cho đưa ra, sát biển chiến tức về phép tổng tổng tổng má rù ví vâ sứ.